so last night was the second and final
presidential debate and i have to tell
you
for me being so desensitized to this
stuff being so used to what we see and
hear from politicians
uh it is actually an outlier it really
is a debate that was superlative
compared to other debates in a number of
different ways
number one joe biden did really well i
didn't expect joe biden to come out in
the way we did i knew he would say
things that would make sense but i
didn't imagine that he was going to be
from a tone and optics perspective um
so strong in comparison to donald trump
i
also didn't imagine that donald trump
was going to come out
um almost despondent and barely able to
even respond to joe biden's attacks for
the first seventy percent of the debate
the last 30 percent going to conspiracy
theories and
things that don't make any sense and it
was one of the most uneven debates i can
imagine watching
i thought back to 2012 the famous
um obama romney debate where romney
made kind of a fool out of himself
starting to say things that didn't make
sense and then trying to get
obama to concede something and obama
just sitting there casually saying
please proceed governor and it was very
uneven
but romney's performance was better than
trump's
last night and joe biden just landing
brutal hit after hit on trump trump
seemed almost
slowed down depressed confused
looked like he was taking physical
punches rather than simply metaphorical
ones
in the first debate biden wasn't nearly
as strong
as i'd like to see and trump was kind of
annoying with his childish interruptions
but it was not
so lopsided last night's debate
stunningly one-sided so let's look at
some clips
one quick note excellent job by
moderator kristen welker
she had total control of the debate the
entire time there was no point at which
she was in the chris wallace position of
almost having to beg trump
to stop interrupting uh she in full
control of the entire debate
very very good to see and even from the
get-go i mean trump entering with no
mask
joe biden with a mask all emblematic
a microcosm of the entire portion of the
debate about coronavirus
which was as usual and as expected one
of the worst parts of the debate for
donald trump
trump immediately trying to defend his
work on coronavirus defending the
indefensible
and predictably making no sense talking
about what he's been able to do with
goggles
and how other world leaders have praised
him we have
a problem that's a worldwide problem
this is a worldwide problem
but i've been congratulated by the heads
of many countries on what we've been
able to do
with the if you if you take a look at
what we've done in terms of
goggles and masks and gowns and
everything else and in particular
ventilators we're now making ventilators
all over the world thousands and
thousands a month distributing them
all over the world joe biden shot out of
a cannon
immediately says listen any president
who oversees
220 000 deaths they can't continue to be
president you don't reelect
someone on the heels of such a failure
two hundred and twenty thousand
americans dead
if you hear nothing else i say tonight
hear this
anyone is responsible for not taking
control
in fact not saying i'm i take no
responsibility initially
anyone who's responsible for that many
deaths should not remain
as president of the united states of
america we're in a situation where there
are a thousand
deaths a day now a thousand deaths a day
and there are over 70 000 new
cases per day compared to
what's going on in europe as the new
england medical journal said they're
starting from a very
low rate we're starting from a very high
rate
the expectation is we'll have another
two hundred thousand americans dead
be timed between now and the end of the
year if we just wore
these masks the president's own advisers
have told them
we could save a hundred thousand lives
and we're in a circumstance where the
president thus far and still has
no plan no comprehensive plan
so really not a good start for donald
trump and it got even worse donald trump
tried pulling this thing about
i shut down travel from china and biden
said i was xenophobic
and biden with this was when i thought
joe is really ready
biden with a perfect line which is you
are xenophobic
but not because you shut down travel
from china my response is he is
xenophobic but not because he shut down
access from china and he did it late
after 40 countries had already done that
in addition to that what he did he made
sure that we had 44 people that were in
there
in china trying to get to wuhan to
determine what exactly the source was
what did the president say in january
he said no he said this is he's being
transparent
the president of china is being
transparent we owe more debt of
gratitude we ought to we have to thank
him
this is when in watching trump just
stand there
shaking his head i realized this was not
during the muted microphone phase of the
debate
i realized trump didn't have it trump
was not up to the task
last night and indeed this is where it
really started going off the rails
uh trump been trying to defend his
record bizarrely goes into talking about
joe biden's basement
and joe biden making money that i guess
trump thinks is not
appropriate money for joe biden to have
made your reaction
over soon i say we're learning to live
with it we have no choice we can't lock
ourselves up in a basement like
joe does he has the he has the ability
to lock himself up i don't know he's
obviously made a lot of money someplace
but he has this thing about living in a
basement people can't do that
by the way i as the president couldn't
do that i'd love to put myself in the
basement
so that's an example of trump throwing a
punch that just missed everything like
it just hit nothing
and joe biden in a bunch of these
moments joe biden just smiled and
laughed
and i think that's the right way to
brush off
trump's silly conspiratorial ad hominems
because if you try to deal with it
directly
i don't know how you do it without
sounding defensive pete boot edge edge
on fox news has had some good examples
of when he's put on the defensive
and he hits back and it doesn't seem
like he's on the defensive
he's back to offense i just don't know
that biden would have been able to do it
in this format without
actually seeming defensive which you
don't necessarily want to do so i think
biden just laughing this stuff off was
was perfect it's the right way to do it
joe biden then going after rudy giuliani
not mentioning the borat fiasco but
mentioning many other things that
triggered donald trump
well his buddy rudy giuliani he's being
used as a russian
pawn he's being fed information that is
russian
that is not true and then what happens
nothing happens and then you find out
that
everything is going on here about russia
is wanting to make sure
that i do not get elected the next
president united states
because they know i know them and they
know
me so trump also unable to take that on
and then again donald trump saying when
the topic of his taxes came up
that now his line is he prepaid millions
of dollars
at the town hall when trump asked about
paying 750 in taxes
trump said well that's a statutory
amount that's like a minimum
fee almost like you pay when you file
and my my accountant said i paid that
didn't make any sense now we have a
different story which is
he actually prepaid millions of dollars
and i guess that's why they're not on
his return
it's impossible to decipher what he's
talking about none of it is believable
and then this is where it almost seemed
like trump
was was unaware of his surroundings and
not even understanding what he was
saying
he starts using this mafia-esque
language
to accuse biden of giving money to the
big men
nobody could understand what he was
talking about well
i called my accountants underwrote it
i'm going to release them as soon as we
can i want to do it and it'll show how
successful how great this company is but
much more importantly than that
people were saying 750 i asked them
a week ago i said what did i pay they
said sir you prepaid
tens of millions of dollars i prepaid my
tax tens over the last
number of years tens of millions of
dollars i prepaid
because at some point they think it's an
estimate they think i may have to pay
tax
so i already prepaid it nobody told me
that
nobody told you that excuse me and it
wasn't written whenever they write this
they keep talking about 750 which i
think is a filing fee
but let me just tell you i prepaid
millions and millions of dollars in
taxes
number one number two i don't make money
from china you do
i don't make money from ukraine you do i
don't make money from russia
you made three and a half million
dollars joe and your son gave you
they even have a statement that we have
to give 10 percent
to the big man you're the big man i
think i don't know maybe you're not
trump continuing to say by the way
five years later he can't release his
taxes
even the ones from i guess like 2012 at
this point
because he's under audit or arded as
trump often says and then again
trump saying biden gives money to the
big men
one of the most incoherent attacks of
the night joe biden just saying
this is really simple show us the
returns to talk about this more broadly
respond very quickly and then i'll get
to my question why did
he's been saying this for four years
show us
just show us stop playing around you've
been saying for four years you're gonna
release your taxes
nobody knows mr president what they do
know is you're not
paying your taxes or you're paying taxes
that are so low
when last time he said what he paid he
said i only pay that little because i'm
smart
i know how to gain the system come on
come on folks come on man becoming a
very very popular meme from this debate
come on man
now this is a really special moment
because trump tries a hunter biden
conspiracy
and refers to some very strong email and
joe biden perfectly explains that
americans pay tariffs
that trump put on china trump still
doesn't understand how tariffs work
let me know i have to respond to that
okay very quickly
after spending 10 minutes in office and
being in air force two
number one number two there's a very
strong
email talking about your family wanting
to make
10 million dollars a year for
introductions president trump
on china policy though what's this
nobody are you going to do
what specifically are you going to do to
make china pay you've said you're going
to
pay china they're paying billions and
billions of dollars i just gave 28
billion dollars
i just gave 28 billion dollars to our
farmers taxpayers china
it's what taxpayers money income yeah
you know the taxpayer is it's called
china
china paid 28 billion and you know what
they did to pay it joe
they devalued their currency and they
also paid up
look at how this is four years into the
presidency
and donald trump still thinks that when
you tariff china
chinese people send the united states
treasury money no
our companies when they import things
from china
pay the tariffs the money comes
from american companies and i've said
before
i don't know if trump still doesn't
understand that or is pretending
not to understand it when the topic of
health care came up trump started
talking about
joe wants socialized health care he's
going to destroy
medicare and social security none of
which is true
some of which we wish were true but it's
not biden astutely pointing out
you're running against me i beat those
other people why are you talking about
other people's policies
when he says public action he's talking
about socialized medicine
and when he and and healthcare when he
talks about a public option
he's talking about destroying your
medicare totally destroyed and
destroying your social security
and this whole country will come down
you know bernie sanders tried it
in his state he tried it in a state his
governor was a very liberal governor
they want to make it work
okay it does vice president
very confused guy he thinks he's running
against somebody else he's running
against
joe biden i beat all those other people
because i disagreed
with them joe biden he's running against
joe biden quickly lining up
retorts to all attacks which was great
to see
wasn't ready in the first debate on that
front
this was maybe the worst moment of the
debate for trump trump
again pulling out this line of attacking
so-called
democrat cities and states which is a
message of complete division
and and this this was pitch perfect
joe biden perfectly responding to that
divisive message saying listen i'm not
going to talk about blue states in red
states i'm a democrat running for
president
i will be the president for everybody
regardless of what state you're in
couldn't have teed it up any better for
joe biden
it was really a big bailout for badly
run democrat
cities and states all right if i get
elected i'm not gonna i'm running as a
proud democrat but i'm gonna be an
american president
i don't see red states in blue states
what i see
is american united states and folks
every single state out there finds
themselves
in trouble they're going to start laying
off whether they're red or blue
cops firefighters first responders
because
teachers because they have to balance
their budget and you see trump just kind
of nodding and shaking his head like a
fool during that one
even trump seemed to realize that
attacking half the country
when you're depending on a handful of
key battleground states to win
which are very much split blue red
democrat republican not a good idea
the next worst moment for trump was when
he casually
went xenophobic the topic of immigration
came up
and trump had no choice i guess in his
mind in order to really own biden
than to talk about low iq hispanic
immigrants just really
bottom of the barrel stuff here only the
really i hate to say this
but those with the lowest iq they might
come back okay president trump let's
give vice president biden a chance to
respond and then we're going to move on
to this you don't know the law joe
vice president biden your response and
then one hilarious moment was
trump calling himself the best president
of uh four black people since abe
lincoln
and joe biden sarcastically came back
and said you know abe lincoln over here
hasn't done this that and the other
thing
trump doesn't understand it trump
doesn't understand humor trump doesn't
understand satire it's it's actually
sociologically the most interesting
moment we talk about how trump has no
sense of humor he doesn't seem to get
jokes trump is actually visibly confused
by this joke and asks what joe biden is
talking about president biden let me ask
you
very quickly and then i have a follow-up
question for you abraham lincoln here is
one of the most racist presidents we've
had in modern history
he pours fuel on every single
racist fire every single one he started
off his campaign coming down the
escalator saying he's getting rid of
those
mexican rapists he's banned muslims
because they're muslims
he has moved around and made everything
worse
across the board he says about the poor
boys
last time we were on stage here he said
i told him to stand down
and stand ready come on this guy is a
dog whistle about as big as a foghorn
president trump i'm going to give you 10
seconds to respond and then i have a
father he made a reference to abraham
lincoln where did that come in
i mean you said abraham line where did
that no
no you said i said not since abraham
lincoln
has anybody done what i've done for the
black community and i'm gonna say i'm
abraham lincoln i said
not since abraham lincoln has anybody
done what i've done for the black
this is just so funny and biden can't
help but laugh
trump doesn't understand satire it's
lost on him
i don't know what trump understands less
satire or how tariffs work he seems to
not understand either of them
and then final stunning moments after
the end of the debate
we saw melania trump and jill biden walk
onto the stage
melania approaching donald trump they
seem to barely even say a word to each
other
they look miserable trump not putting a
mask on joe biden immediately puts a
mask on at the end of the debate
emblematic of their respective
perspectives on coronavirus jill biden
embraces joe biden
they look like a normal couple the
trumps look miserable
biden both jill and joe biden
try to catch trump and melania's eye to
say bye
to wave by trump doesn't even
acknowledge the biden's presence on
stage
the biden's wave trumps start just
walking off and then you see
it's either melania ripping her hand out
of from trump's hand
or vice versa but just completely
emblematic of everything
that these people represent so a
terrible debate for donald trump the way
i would
summarize it if you if you said how does
it how do you distill what happened
trump spent 90 minutes talking about his
problems
whereas and his victimhood and his being
a martyr
while joe biden talked about the
problems affecting the american people
rather than about joe biden himself
and if you have ever seen a more
lopsided presidential debate
let me know because i can't remember one
we've got uh just a little over a week
left until this election
trump is going to try funny business to
win it
we are at the election 40 45 million
people have already voted that's about a
third of the expected electorate or more
let's do it this is it there's nothing
else to wait for no more debates
you can vote now in a vast majority of
states either by mail or early
let's just do it and let me know your
thoughts about the debate in these last
10 days
on twitter where you can find me at
dpakman
today's program is made possible in part
by surf shark which is a premium vpn
service that protects you online and
they are giving
my audience 83 off a two-year plan
plus three extra months free on top of
that which makes all of it about two
bucks a month
surf shark hides your ip address which
helps protect you
from things like government surveillance
big tech companies tracking you
internet service providers logging and
selling your internet history
surfshark encrypts your data and keeps
you safe from hackers
it can block ads and protect you from
viruses
and surf shark never logs your internet
activity
and best of all you can install it on
unlimited devices i use it every time
i'm connected to the internet
surf shark is giving my audience 83
off a two-year plan plus three extra
month
free so that comes out to just about two
dollars a month which is
almost nothing relative to the peace of
mind you will have
while browsing online just go to
surfshark.deal
pacman i've put the link underneath this
video and make sure to use the coupon
code pacman